做交易的人几乎没有不复盘的
收盘以后打开软件看一圈今天哪个赚了
哪个亏了
哪一笔做的漂亮
哪一笔没做好
认真一点还会截图做笔记
写信的体会
日积月累
攒了不少东西
但有一个问题大多数人不太敢追问自己
付了这么久
交易真的在变好吗
账户曲线真的因为复盘在往上走吗
如果诚实回答
很多人会发现自己复盘和不复盘的时候
好像差别没有想象中那么大
偶尔灵光一闪
觉得自己悟到了点什么
过两天就回到老样子
一直在复盘
一直在原地
问题出在哪
出在很多人在复盘的时候
其实不是在分析交易
而是在挑一个让自己舒服的解释
你仔细回想一下
就明白了
一笔赚钱的交易
你复盘的时候会怎么归因
你回归到自己的判断上
我看对了这个形态
我才屯了这波节奏
我坚持了自己的逻辑
功劳全在自己头上
那一笔亏钱的呢归因的方向就变了
运气不好
突然出了个利空
那个角度破
太坑人了
要不是那根针少到我止损
我本来就是对的
责任全是在外面的
这个东西在心理学上有个名字叫归因偏差
赚呢是我厉害
亏了设市场坑我
偶尔一两笔这么想
问题不大
但累积起来
它会慢慢把你的复盘记录
变成一本很要命的东西
一本以为自己写的历史功劳全归自己
一锅全给行情
你在这个过程里得到的不是对交易更深的认知
而是对自己的感觉
一次次保护你
不断在告诉自己
逻辑没问题
系统没问题
只是运气还没来
然后带着这个被安抚好的心情
第二天继续犯同样的错误
这种复盘复100遍
底层的交易能力不会变好
哪怕一丁点
那怎么停下来
复盘唯一正确的对象不是盈亏
结果是你的决策过程
一笔交易从你决定进场到决定离场中间
你做了哪些动作
是在看到什么具体信号的时候决定动手的
这个信号在你的系统里是提前规定好的
还是你临场觉得看起来不错
就进去了
进场的时候设止损了吗
射了之后
盘中你有没有因为害怕手动把止损往下挪过
止盈是你进场前就规划好的
还是看到利润开始回吐的时候
慌慌张张
平掉的
这些东西才是复盘真正该翻出来看的材料
至于这笔交易最后赚了还是亏了
那是你做完上面这一连串动作之后
自然产生的结果
你老盯着结果去复盘
等于在排气管里找毛病
永远找不到引擎上那颗松掉的螺丝
这就是为什么复盘必须先有书面计划
没有计划的复盘跟没有菜谱的炒菜
尝咸淡是一回事
你尝了一口觉得咸
但你不知道是放多了一勺盐还是酱油倒多了
因为你根本不记得自己放了什么
书面计划
不需要复杂
进场之前花2分钟写上唐字就够了
第一行我在什么条件下进场
第二行对了怎么办
错了怎么办
第三行我这笔最多亏多少
有了这三行
复盘的性质就变了
不再是看看今天发生了什么
而是拿出这三行字
对照你的实际操作
一行一行核对计划写
日线收盘站稳20日均线进场
你实际进场的时候是日线真的收盘了吗
还是盘中一根阳线就冲进去了
计划写错了
亏三个点止损
你实际达到止损位的时候
是秒砍了
还是犹豫了一下
手动把止损拖远了
或者干脆取消了计划
写对了
拿到前高附近减仓
你实际是拿到了还是中途被震出去了
还是贪婪没减
又坐了一轮过山车
一行一行对对上了这笔交易
不管你是赚了还是亏了
你的执行是合格的
对不上
这笔交易在赚执行层面也出了不该出的错
把这些和计划之间的偏差
一笔一笔记下来
累积一段时间
你才会开始看到自己真正的模式
你可能一直在同一个坑里摔
只是之前看盈亏的时候根本注意不到他
比如你发现你去十次复盘里
有六七次你都在盘中手动挪过止损
这不是某一次的问题
这是你系统在执行层有一个盲区
这个盲区不解决
你练什么技术都白搭
但如果你之前只盯着盈亏
你永远不会发现这个盲区
因为有时候拿了止损来赚钱
你就觉得那次没问题
这就是复盘
真正的价值不是帮你证明自己行
而是帮你找到那些重复出现的
自己都不太好意思面对的错误
然后一个一个修掉
讲到这里
你心里肯定有个疑问了
盘中行情是会变的
计划是盘前写的
盘前和盘中的行情经常对不上
那照着计划复盘是不是太死板了
这个想法挺普遍的
但他搞错了一个很关键的东西
计划的意义不是让你像个机器人一样
从头至进到尾
而是让你复盘的时候手里有一把尺子
如果你连计划都没有
盘中临时做的决定
复盘的时候你根本没有东西可以对照
你当时只是感觉不对就走了
事后你怎么分析分析不了
因为感觉这个东西没法复盘
有了书面计划
哪怕盘中的情况和预判不一样
你改动了执行
你至少知道执行和计划之间的偏差在哪
知道偏差在哪
就可以分析这个偏差是合理的应对
还是自己又在慌乱中乱按
没有计划
连偏差都看不到
脑子里只有一笔模糊的盈亏
所以复盘不是马后炮
不是给自己打分
不是找理由让自己好受一点
复盘是校准
是你把进场前定的那个标准拿出来
跟你盘中真实操作放在一起对比
找到两者之间的差距
然后在下一次进场之前
把这个差距写进新的计划里
让它不再发生
回到开头那个问题
你付了那么久
交易为什么还在原地打转
可能不是努力不够
是复盘的方向
一直偏着
把复盘从总结盈亏改成核对自己的决策
坚持一个月
你的复盘记录才会真正变成交易的手册
而不是一本反复安慰自己的日记